[Music]
welcome back
okay so
you know how much i love dynamical
systems and i spend a lot of time
thinking about how we can use machine
learning to model dynamical systems from
data
so i thought it'd be useful to give you
just kind of a high level overview of
some of the things we think about when
we're working with dynamical systems
okay
this is just generally good to know and
this is just you know a very very high
level kind of topical overview of some
of the things you would learn in a
dynamical systems class at you know a
mile high
so dynamical system is
any system that evolves or changes in
time according to some rules now that's
very very vague
uh if you have an apple falling
right it is a dynamical system the
position of that apple evolves it
changes in time according to f equals ma
newton's second law
a fluid flow is a dynamical system it
evolves according to the navy or stokes
equations a pendulum an automobile
but even very very very complicated
systems like your brain
is a dynamical system all of the neurons
in your brain are connected and there
are some set of rules that determine how
they fire and interact we don't know
those rules or we don't know all of
those rules we can't write them down in
an equation but they certainly exist and
that system certainly evolves in time
okay so dynamical systems essentially
describe the changing world around us
from how a disease spreads across a
continent to the climate to your brain
and you know
a million other things that are really
really interesting that we want to model
predict estimate and control
and increasingly we're doing this with
data
so i'll just tell you some things about
dynamical systems that i find
interesting this is by no means a
complete list
okay so um
in this kind of progression of
increasing non-linearity
and i'll tell you what i mean by
non-linearity in a minute kind of the
simple dynamical systems are dynamical
systems that are linear things like a
pendulum that has a small angle
approximation or a small displacement
theta
or a linear spring mass damper system
you just have springs and masses and
dampers connected and you see these
systems oscillate
linear essentially means
that if i have two solutions
of that dynamical system i have two
i start from two different initial
conditions you know theta one and theta
two
and i know how those evolve
if i add those two initial conditions
together i just add the solutions and
that's the solution of the new system
so it means that linear superposition
holds if i have two solutions of this
system
and i add them together that's also a
solution of the system
and that's only true for linear
dynamical systems where the dynamics are
described by a matrix
evolution
now you can get mildly non-linear
dynamical systems things like
hamiltonian or lagrangian dynamics this
duffing oscillator is how a particle
would behave in a potential well with
two wells these two kind of bowls here
and if i had a little bead that was
rolling around on this wire
its dynamics would be non-linear and
there would be multiple fixed points
given by where the the bead would be
fixed so at the bottom of these green
wells the bead would be fixed that's a
fixed point and at the top
kind of this pink part here that saddle
point if i perfectly balance the bead it
would also stay fixed so this system has
some fixed points and some dynamics and
i'll talk more about that later
and then in kind of the far progression
you have systems that are fully chaotic
now they
are still deterministic i can still
write down a differential equation or
some rules that describe how the system
evolves in time
but i have some limited forecast ability
if i
if i don't measure my initial state
absolutely perfectly or if i don't know
my dynamics to perfect precision
after some amount of time my prediction
is going to diverge from the truth this
is called a sensitive dependence on
initial conditions or chaos
things like the double pendulum or the
lorentz attractor
weather models turbulent fluids those
all exhibit chaos and those are kind of
special and interesting nonlinear
dynamical systems
okay good
and in a previous video i showed you
kind of the anatomy of a dynamical
system you have
the time derivative of a state is equal
to some you know
function of that state
x dot equals f of x
so x is a vector that describes the
minimal state you need to describe your
system so in this case in a pendulum the
minimal state needed to describe that
pendulum is not just theta but theta and
theta dot because if i'm at a given
theta i could be passing through it this
way or passing through it this way and
you need theta and theta dot to uniquely
determine your state
so that's what the vector x is
and then the time derivative of that
state the the way that that state
changes in time
is given by f of x some function of the
state
and this might be derived from the euler
lagrange equations or f equals m a or
hamilton the hamiltonian equations
but these are essentially the rules for
how that state changes in time and we
encode this as a differential equation
good
now oftentimes we want to linearize our
system so i told you that this pendulum
behaves linearly near the bottom if i if
i take this pendulum and i just kick it
a little bit it behaves linearly
but it is non-linear if i have a large
amplitude if i if i increase
that theta to something you know close
to pi and let it go i'll get nonlinear
effects so it is a nonlinear dynamical
system
what we often do is we look near a fixed
point so by fixed point i mean a
state x
where f of x is equal to zero so if i
have the pendulum in the down position
with a zero velocity it's not going to
move x dot is equal to zero in the down
position with zero velocity when theta
and theta dot are zero
that's called a fixed point
there's another fixed point in the
pendulum up position in the theta equals
pi theta dot equals zero so i have theta
equals pi
and i start it perfectly still at theta
dot equals zero that's also a fixed
point it's unstable but it's a fixed
point if i perfectly balance it it'll
stay there
and so this pendulum system has two
fixed points where the vector field
where the the dynamics are equal to zero
and the system would stay put okay
so what we're going to do with
linearization is we're going to zoom
into those fixed points and try to see
what the linear dynamics are for small
angles around those fixed points
and the way we do it is we say okay well
we're zooming into a neighborhood around
x bar our fixed point and we're going to
look at small delta x's in that
neighborhood so x is going to be x bar
plus delta x and we're going to try to
build a model for how delta x evolves in
time
so d dt of delta x remember because x
bar is a fixed point x bar dot is zero
it's just a constant
so the time derivative of delta x is
equal to x dot
which is f of x
which is f of x bar plus delta x
i think you see where i'm going now
we're going to tailor expand this bit
and we're going to kind of break apart f
of x bar and the delta x
and so this you can tailor expand this
and you get f of x bar which again we
knew this is a fixed point so that's
equal to zero
plus uh the jacobian derivative of this
vector f with respect to the vector x
evaluated at the fixed point
dotted into delta x
plus higher order terms you know delta x
squared delta x cubed and remember we've
zoomed in so that we're close to this
fixed point x bar so delta x is small so
these higher order terms are very very
small and we can kind of neglect these
and so what this means is that we
essentially get a dynamical system that
is approximately linear for small
neighborhoods around these fixed points
so the time derivative of
of my
position around that fixed point
is equal to this jacobian derivative
this is just a matrix okay uh you
basically take so if f is f1 f2 and if x
has components x1 x2 then you would take
a matrix of partial derivatives partial
f1 partial x1 partial f1 partial x2
partial f2 partial x1 partial f2 partial
x2 this is a matrix of derivatives
evaluated at x bar and so at the end of
the day what you get out is a matrix
system of ordinary differential
equations an honest to goodness linear
system x dot equals ax
and that's nice because we know how to
handle linear systems it's very hard to
handle these non-linear systems but we
know a lot about these linear systems we
look at its eigenvalues and its
eigenvectors and we learn if it's stable
or unstable we learn what directions it
might be unstable along
and that can be pretty pretty useful
so that's kind of why we linearize is
because we know lots about linear
systems and so
that's a general strategy when you have
a nonlinear system is to find the fixed
points linearize around the fixed points
and do linear analysis around that
system
so
this is kind of hopefully a refresher
and i talk about this a lot in my
control bootcamp
if you have some differential equation x
dot equals ax this is your linearization
then we know how this system x is going
to evolve for any future time t this
could be you know a million years in the
future
i just take the matrix exponential of e
to the a t
times my initial condition so i can take
any initial condition and advance it as
far as i want forward or backward in
time just by multiplying it by this
matrix exponential e to the a t and
that's easy to compute in modern
computers
uh it's also useful to have linear
systems because you can essentially use
the eigenvectors of a to define a new
coordinate system that diagonalizes your
dot your dynamics
so if t
are eigenvectors of my a matrix
and i define a new coordinate system so
that z is essentially in that
eigenvector coordinate system
then i can write down what the z dot
dynamics are and you'll have to kind of
write this down slowly and convince
yourself that this is true
but if i have you know x dot equals t z
dot then z dot equals t inverse x dot
and x dot is a x so z dot equals t
inverse a x
and x equal t z so z dot equals t
inverse a t z
now this might seem like i made things
worse it definitely looks like i made
things worse but if
this t coordinate system are very
specially chosen to be eigenvectors of a
then this matrix here actually becomes a
diagonal matrix
okay so
t inverse a t is a diagonal matrix if t
are the eigenvectors of a
and so what this allows me to do is if i
have a linear system and i find the
eigenvectors of a
i get a new coordinate system where my
dynamics are decoupled and linear very
very useful so that means that z1 dot
only depends on z1 and z2 dot only
depends on z2 and so on and so forth
it's a decoupled system it's very easy
to simulate and predict and understand
good
and this is kind of the eigenvalue
equation that you would use to find the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of that a
matrix
and there's an interpretation that i
absolutely love and i'm going to tell
you because i think it's super cool is
that if i take this this expression here
for x of t equals e to the a t x naught
and i expand out this e to the a t here
in eigenvector coordinates i i get
something very simple i get this t e to
the lambda t
big t inverse times x naught and again
this doesn't look simple but i'm going
to explain why it is
so what this means is that i can take
any initial condition x naught and i can
get
that
i can flow that system forward in time
and tell you what it where it will be
after time t using this expression
so i want to walk you through what this
means physically so the first part here
x naught times big t inverse what that
does is it takes my initial condition x
at time 0 and it maps me into my
eigenvector coordinate system z at time
0.
now in that eigenvector coordinate
system it's really easy to advance the
system because the dynamics are diagonal
i just advanced z1
z2 and you know and all the way to zn
independently because it's diagonal
and so it's easy to advance z naught
time t forward by multiplying by this
diagonal exponential matrix this is just
a an exponential
a diagonal matrix of exponentials
but now we're still in eigenvector
coordinates so we want to map back into
our original coordinate system by
multiplication with t
so i think that's just a really cool
interpretation of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors for linear dynamical
systems is that if i have an initial
condition i can map into eigenvector
coordinates with t inverse
there in these eigenvector coordinates
it's easy to advance the dynamics
forward in time because the system is
decoupled and diagonal
that's this e to the lambda t
and then after i've advanced my system
and eigenvector coordinates i finally
map out back to my original physical
space uh by matrix multiplication with
big t
okay good
so uh let's take a step back we're
talking about dynamical systems even
non-linear systems often have fixed
points and we can linearize around those
fixed points
and looking at the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors can be very useful it gives
us a local coordinate system it tells us
if i have a unstable eigenval value then
that corresponding eigenvector is the
direction in which the system is going
to blow up
so it tells you kind of how the system
evolves locally
in time around those fixed points
good
okay so let's look at a more complicated
system remember that middle system i
showed you with the three fixed points
that's the stuffing equation x dot
equals velocity so the time derivative
of position equals velocity the time
derivative of velocity equals x minus x
cubed
this is a very simple differential
equation for the motion of a particle in
a double potential well
and you know you can kind of verify for
yourself that this system has three
fixed points so for there to be a fixed
point where the right hand side is zero
v has to equal zero
and then x minus x cubed has to equal
zero and that's only true if x is equal
to zero or plus or minus one so these
are the three fixed points of the system
and you can essentially linearize this
non-linear differential equation about
any one of these three fixed points
so and again this is what the what the
actual physics looks like this is the
phase portrait of this dynamical system
where you have this potential here
which is essentially given by
x to the fourth minus x squared
and what you have here on these axes
down here this is the x-axis and this is
the v-axis
and if i have a point and i start here
my particle starts here and i'm rolling
around this potential well
i can visualize that in this phase
portrait as going around in a circle
here so if i start at this position with
uh
zero velocity and you know some position
x
what's going to happen is i'm going to
roll down the hill and my velocity is
going to increase to a maximum here
then i'm going to roll up the hill and
my velocity is going to decrease
i'm going to turn around and my velocity
is going to increase in the negative
direction it'll peak here
and then i'll go back up here that's
exactly what this phase portrait is
saying you know i start at this position
x with zero velocity i accelerate until
a maximum velocity here
at the bottom of the well
then i decelerate until i'm at the top
of the other side
then i accelerate back around in the
negative direction and so on and so
forth and with no friction you just go
around and around and around
so it's a very physical picture that
shows you kind of pictorially what the
dynamics are going to be and they're
given by this differential equation
so what you do is when you write down
your differential equation or you
discover this with some machine learning
model you try to find the fixed points
again here there are three fixed points
the bottom of each of the two wells and
then also at the saddle point where if i
was perfectly aligned i would stay there
forever
uh
yeah and i think i told you that this is
essentially you can derive this from
newton's second law f equals ma where
you have a potential field and the
potential is given by x to the fourth
minus x squared
like this is literally what would happen
if you had a roller coaster that was
shaped like this with no friction and
you were kind of on that track moving
around
okay
good so if we want to zoom into one of
these fixed points one of these three
fixed points and we want to know what
the dynamics will locally do near that
fixed point we compute this uh jacobian
of partial derivatives that's what i
told you before
is essentially the first term is partial
of this equation with respect to x
that's zero
the partial of this equation with
respect to v is one
the partial of this equation with
respect to x is one minus three x
squared
and the partial of this equation with
respect to v is 0.
if there was friction there would be a
term down here because this would have a
v term
and so you can evaluate this jacobian
this matrix of partial derivatives at
any of these three fixed points you just
plug in these fixed points to this x bar
squared here
and essentially
what you would find is that
the eigenvalues of these two green fixed
points are neutrally stable the
eigenvalues of this a matrix would be
plus and minus i omega meaning that the
system just oscillates forever
and the eigenvalues of this fixed point
here are going to be a saddle point
they're going to be plus or minus 1.
and that means that one of those
directions is unstable if i take this
roller coaster i put my roller coaster
right here or the car and i push it a
tiny bit to the left or the right or i
give it a tiny bit of velocity it will
unstably move away from that fixed point
and you can learn that by looking at
these linearizations
okay good
and
the eigenvalues tell you if it's stable
or unstable the corresponding
eigenvector tells you along what
directions the system is unstable so
actually these red curves here these
kind of 45 degree angle curves those are
the eigenvectors
of of that fixed point and you can
verify it yourself compute the
eigenvalues of this eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of this linearization
for the saddle point for the zero zero
fixed point and you'll find that the two
eigenvectors are kind of 45 degree
angles like this picture here
and so if you take those eigenvectors
those linear subspaces and you continue
them you sweep out stable and unstable
manifolds for the system
and so here's another case i really like
where it's a non-linear differential
equation with a single fixed point at
the origin
and if you locally linearized you would
find that this system is a saddle point
one of the directions is stable the y
direction is stable
and the x direction is unstable
and so if i start with an initial
condition here i'm going to move towards
the fixed point in the y direction and
then away from it in the x direction
and so you can then take those
eigenvectors and continue them and learn
that there is a stable manifold and an
unstable manifold and this is very very
useful in dynamical systems
uh and you know you can have more and
more complicated kind of versions of
this uh where
these saddle points tend to uh amplify
uncertainty so this is kind of one of
the the ways you can almost think about
chaos is um
amplifying uncertainty
so if i had these kind of balls of
uncertainty and i advance them forward
in time they're going to end up kind of
squashing along this uh this unstable
manifold
along the direction of the stable
manifold so things get stretched and
folded in these systems
good another really really important
part of dynamical systems are
bifurcations
so oftentimes you have a differential
equation
that has some parameter that you can
vary
so in fluid flows often it's the
velocity of the incoming flow or the
size of the object in the you know the
wing in your in your wind tunnel
there's all kinds of bifurcations in
dynamical systems if you're looking at
the spread of a disease like covid19
the bifurcation parameter might be
uh you know the infection rate or
something like that and so this
parameter mu you often want to know how
your dynamical system is going to change
as i change a parameter of the system
so there's the state of the system x and
there's the parameter of the system mu
and this is kind of a neat one x dot
equals mu x minus x cubed so if mu is
negative you have a stable system and
everything just contracts to x equals
zero but if mu is positive you have
something that's linearly unstable and
it's going to grow exponentially until
it gets large enough to get counteracted
by this
saturating the stabilizing cubic term
and so you can write it like this as x
times mu minus x squared so again if mu
is positive my system exponentially
grows
until it's balanced
by that term
and so you can draw these bifurcation
diagrams so on the x-axis here is the
this is the mu axis and what we're
showing here these are the dynamics in x
uh for a fixed mu value
so mu zero is right here
and so for negative mu
all of my x dynamics no matter where i
start in x i go to the origin it's
stable dynamics
but when mu is positive let's say for
this value here positive mu
what will happen if i start anywhere
near the origin is i'll actually grow
exponentially
until i hit this uh mu equals x squared
parabola until x squared equals mu
and then it balances that term out okay
and again you can look at the local
linearization by computing this jacobian
and you can see if it's stable or
unstable
and you get this additional branch
of stable points for positive mu okay so
so essentially now for positive mu
i have a set of solutions or fixed
points at uh
x equals plus or minus square root of mu
that's what we have in this kind of
parabola here
and you can look at the stability of the
the kind of new fixed points or the
original x equals zero fixed point
uh another one in kind of higher
dimensions is this hop bifurcation this
comes up all the time in instabilities
of physical systems like fluids
uh where again you have a minimal state
x and y
you have some linear dynamics here and
if mu is negative the system is linearly
stable
if mu becomes positive as you as you
pass through the mu equals zero point it
becomes unstable and a new kind of
branch of solutions this new
limit cycle
behavior
emerges where the system actually wants
to be on this fixed amplitude limit
cycle that balances out this cubic term
okay and again you can write this in
polar coordinates and get a really
really simple representation uh that's
directly analogous to this pitchfork
bifurcation
now i want to point out that this is
like an entire graduate level course
looking at all the bifurcations and all
of the ways to analyze these dynamical
systems and to transform them and solve
them and analyze them i'm showing you a
cartoon of the kinds of things that can
happen and the kinds of things we care
about in dynamical systems this is just
a tiny glimpse
into this into this world
but we know that systems do bifurcate
they do change like dramatically and
qualitatively sometimes when i just
tiny you know tiny changes in my
parameter can sometimes cause kind of
big big changes in my system that's what
bifurcations are
you can also have dynamics in discrete
time so what i was showing you earlier
are continuous dynamics the time
derivative of the state equals some
some function that's a continuous
differential equation
you can also have discrete time
dynamical systems like this logistic map
here which describes population dynamics
so the way you would think about this
maybe x is the population of bunnies at
year k
and so if i have you know 10 bunny or
whatever some number of bunnies at year
k
i can compute this right hand side and
it tells me how many bunnies i have the
next year and then i plug that in here
and it tells me how many bunnies i have
two years later and i plug that in three
years later and you can step this
forward year to year to year that's why
it's called discrete time because it
steps forward in time in discrete
chunks
and these systems also have bifurcations
and rich chaotic behavior so for example
this mu here is somehow like a
reproduction rate for those bunnies
and as i sweep through different values
of mu i can get very very different
behavior of those bunny populations in
time
so for you know 3.45 value of mu my
bunny population might pop back and
forth between 4 or five or six or seven
fixed points in a very predictable way
it might just kind of reproducibly go
you know
back and forth between the same
population dynamics
as i increase mu the bunny population
from year to year might bounce around
between all of these kind of fractal
points
and that's a discrete time kind of
analog of chaos okay this is one of my
favorite diagrams this logistic map
okay
and you can get discrete time dynamics
from a continuous time system like this
so if i have a differential equation x
dot equals f of x maybe this is newton's
law or a fluid flow equation or whatever
but i have some continuous system from
physics
i might want to integrate that dynamical
system numerically on a computer i might
want to take an initial condition and be
able to step it forward in time
discretely in a computer
and so the way we would do that is
essentially through this flow map
operator f of t
which takes my initial condition x at
time t naught and it maps it forward to
exit t naught plus t it maps it forward
in time by t
and essentially you do that by
integrating this vector field this f of
f of t you integrate the particle along
that vector field
and as that particle moves along f it
experiences a different f because f is a
function of space so that's why i have
this dependent variable tau here
and what that does is that essentially
establishes a discrete time update like
i showed you earlier like that logistic
map where now if i know my system at
time step k i can get my system at time
step k plus one and if i know it at k
plus one i can get a k plus two and this
essentially forms a computer program or
uh yeah like a program that will step my
system forward in discrete time
intervals
and that can be really useful uh when i
simulate fluid flows for example you
know i might want to drop a bunch of
particles and see how those particles
evect along with that fluid flow
so in this case f would be the fluid
flow field x would be the particle and
i'd want to integrate those particles
through the flow field
in that case f would also be a function
of time because you can tell that my
flow is changing in time
and i can do lots of things like at the
finite time lyapunov exponents i'll have
a whole video talking about these ftle
fields and how we use those to
understand fluids
and those give us the time varying
analogs of those stable and unstable
manifolds i told you about earlier
and those can be very very useful
integrating particles through the flow
can be really really useful for
understanding things like how mixing
occurs in my dynamical system if i have
a flow field like you know this is a
plate that's moving up and down in a
fluid and i might want to understand how
fluid is entrained or mixed maybe i drop
a buoy in the ocean or i drop some
tracer particles i want to know how
those are going to mix throughout the
ocean i'd have to integrate those
through that dynamical system
and that gets us to chaos which again i
mentioned this a little bit
chaotic systems have this
mixing effect
that even if i have a very tight packet
of initial conditions so all this movie
will play again my initial conditions
start in a very tight cube
where maybe i have a little bit of
uncertainty in where i started
and very very rapidly if i integrate
those initial conditions through this
chaotic dynamical system this lorentz
system
they stay together for a little while
but after not too long they start to
stretch
and eventually they're going to stretch
and fold and mix along this entire
attractor
and so
that idea of mixing
is really key to chaos or a sensitive
dependence on initial conditions even if
i have a pretty tight distribution of
initial conditions
after some finite amount of time i
really can't tell you know where i'm
going to be because they eventually mix
along this attractor
so i'm going to have a whole video on
chaotic dynamical systems and how we
analyze them statistically
what chaos means examples of chaotic
systems but here i just wanted to give
you kind of this teaser to show you that
chaotic systems have the sensitive
dependence on initial conditions
they tend to mix in a finite time there
is a finite time kind of prediction
horizon of where things will go
and after that you can only describe
them in a statistical sense
lots of systems we care about are
chaotic uh
local weather patterns are chaotic you
know we don't know where a hurricane's
gonna go because it's a chaotic
dynamical system fluid flows in general
turbulence is chaotic
and this is one of my favorite
classes of dynamical systems
okay this was a mild high overview of
things i care about in dynamical systems
each one of these vignettes you know is
at least a couple of lectures in a big
dynamical systems class so this is not
you know uh this is just the beginning
of uh of dynamical systems
but i wanted you to know the kinds of
things i think about for example when i
use machine learning to discover
dynamical systems i care about things
like where are the fixed points what are
the local linearizations look like do
they have the right stability do i get
the same statistical mixing in my
machine learning models and in my data
things like that really matter all right
thank you
[Music]